you've been doing some very important
work on the financial aspects of ftth
provision what can you tell us about it
well on behalf of the ftdh council i
have been involved in the cost project
and that's an attempt to calculate
bottom-up the total investment needed to
fiberize the whole of europe
based on the digital digital agenda
digital agenda europe
uh
broadband targets
to uh to estimate
the total cost needed
to give
fiber to all europeans of the all 27
european countries
based on the targets said by the
european commission
sounds like quite a project what are
some of the main conclusions were they
surprising can you tell us a little bit
about it yeah
we were surprised about the results
because the current figure circulating
is about 260 to 280 billion euros and
our results show that uh the total
investment needed
is uh lower
significantly lower we have we have
found a figure which is lower
and we're looking forward to uh to
publish that tomorrow and to present the
results in more detail well that sounds
great news everybody will be welcoming
and in the meantime thanks for sharing
here with us
thank you brian fth connects the world
when are you getting connected
ladies and gentlemen
welcome to munich for the ninth edition
of the ftth conference
creating a brighter future
you